today I'm welcoming a Ranma scavenge to
the program who escaped from the Church
of Scientology's international
headquarters outside Hemet California
back in 2012 he's the father of the
church's leader David Miscavige and I I
don't even know where to start
Ron because there's really so much to
discuss here but I think an interesting
point would be that many people don't
know that the reason your son now is
even in the church is because back I
believe it was in the 1970s you made the
decision to join the church is that
right that's exactly correct David and
what drew you to the Church of
Scientology to begin with well how about
if I do this if it's okay with you yes
can I give you just a thumbnail sketch
so you have an overview so then when I
present what happened with David when he
was a kid yeah it's gonna kind of fit in
okay so just let me do that first well
first of all I was a member of the
church for 42 years I was on staff in
the see organization for 26 and a half
years I escaped on March 25th 2012 and
about a year and three months later two
private investigators were caught around
the corner from where I'm living trying
to buy a house so they could spy on me
from morning till night
they looked suspicious a neighbor called
the cops and the West Allis police come
over I gather the name of Nick pie he
arrested him because the guy started
giving him a bunch of baloney is you
know am I breaking any law he's just
wise enough to him so next and say
you're under arrest you mind if I look
in your your van the guy said no it's
all right so he looked in Duane Powell
that's the name of the private
investigator and his son Daniel Powell
those are the two private investigators
he looked in his van and that the trunk
of that van he found five license plates
from five different states five handguns
a stun gun two rifles one with the
silencer fixed to it and two thousand
rounds of ammunition needless to say
these this gentleman was arrested and he
was interrogated and if you want to hear
the entire interrogation if you
go to my website which is called the
real Ron Miscavige calm you can hear the
entire interrogation as to what went on
well and if this these guys were being
paid ten thousand dollars a week to
follow me to report my every doing
between eight o'clock in the morning and
eight o'clock at night there's a couple
things that happened while this was
going on and one notable thing was this
there's a small town in Wisconsin called
Janesville where I happened to be
shopping one day in the summertime and
unbeknownst to me they were following me
all this time now I had a pocket t-shirt
on and in my left hand pocket tee shirt
pocket I had my cell phone I was putting
groceries in the car I bent over and I
thought that my cell phone was gonna
fall on the ground so I grabbed my left
chest they saw me and they said it looks
like our target they called me the
target yeah he's having is having a
heart attack so they called in and their
contact reg said listen I'll get
somebody on line several minutes later a
gentleman come on the line identified
himself as David Miscavige and said
listen if it's his time to die let him
die don't intervene don't do anything
Wow now that was my son this happening
and also my daughters being disconnected
from me because this is what they do and
by the way I gave you that the name of
that website the real run Miscavige calm
we did specific reason and that is this
the church if you leave they will try to
character assassinate you David they
bought 500 variations of my name and if
you gone any of these other than the
real run Miscavige calm it will take it
to a hate site Wow and their that they
try to character assassinate me this
it's not just me it's standard operating
procedure oh yeah and run just so you
know the bat we've interviewed a number
of former Scientologists so that we have
sort of a scent sense for so if I can
I'd like to pick up a couple of specific
points that sort of were mentioned in
there just to get our audience as much
context as possible you mentioned that
you were
in the church for 42 years what drew you
to the church to begin with what drew me
to the church was this David my son has
had asthma since he was a baby and it
I'll tell you something if you ever have
an infant who has asthma it is a very
pitiful sight then you feel helpless
because here's this little child trying
to catch his breath kind of trying to
save his own life and there's not a
goddamn thing you can do about it
excuse my French my friend but this was
the bane of my existence I got
introduced to Scientology through a
gentleman I met on a business I was
investigating at the time which was
called holiday magic yeah so multi
marketing thing and I met him at an
opportunity meeting he said he was a
Scientologist and he started telling me
about it and it very much struck my
interest long and short of it was this
David all the things I tried with him
nothing worked because I knew this at
best and the doctor I took them to dr.
Zigler would give him a shot of
adrenaline at best you're treating the
symptom so I heard a lot about
Scientology that it was good and that
would help people and they had a thing
called auditing which is another word
for counseling yeah I thought I took
David down to see this gentleman who was
a Scientologist Frank ogle took him in
45 minutes later David come out and said
dad I'm handled and he never had another
severe asthmatic attack as a child I got
to tell you at that moment I think that
was his Epiphany and I think it was at
that moment he decided this is something
I've got to do with my life so let me
know by now Ron just to make sure I
understand at this point none of you are
Scientologists not really we we I
dabbled in it Frank ogle had a little
group that met every Tuesday in his
theater cafeteria that in Woodbury New
Jersey I used to go there every Tuesday
and just kind of you know learn about
the communication formula about
interpersonal relationships but I never
really got into it yeah that was the
point in my life
where I decided if this can do this for
him I got to do it for my whole family
and that got me in the alum did you
eventually become part of the Sea Org
which is a seminar audience know sort of
like the upper epsilon and maybe
management would be an applicable term
of the Church of Scientology it would be
that and let me let me give you a little
bit of an analogy here and let's compare
it to the Catholic Church there are
several ways you can be on what they
call staff in Scientology one would be
you were joined a regular organization
where público to buy services they pay
for a service and they get it delivered
by staff members at that organization
the next level up would be the C
organization which delivers the upper
level so-called Scientology tenants and
then the top level would be like going
to Rome where the Cardinals are and that
would be in Hemet California that would
be the top excellent of management
that's where I was posted all the time I
was in for 26 and a half years and what
happened is I'm living my life and it
got to a point where all my kids were
grown up and I figured I want to help my
church listen man I was the kool-aid
drinker I got to tell you I got people
in Scientology I got him a joint staff
so I was right with that program and
there was no doubts in my mind this was
the best thing I could do for my family
and Roy are those positions well paid or
is it more sort of the appearance of
responsibility that's appealing about
that you think when you do that you're
helping every man woman and child on
this planet to lead a better life that's
what you're indoctrinated into believing
and I'm telling you if people are
interested in reading my book which is
called rootless Scientology my son David
Miscavige and me if you read the book
you will see how on an incremental
little-by-little basis you are led down
the path to believe everything they tell
you as being the absolute truth that l
ron hubbard no matter what he said
that was yen doll you didn't have to
question anything you didn't have to
think for yourself at that point and
that's actually how a lot I mean it's
interesting because that's both how
that's how the Mafia actually works
which is hey listen let's just I'm gonna
do this for you and then someday maybe
you'll just check up on this person for
me and then it's piece by piece you're
sort of sucked in a bit at a time isn't
it exactly right and I'll tell you this
it's so clever and there's so many
little guideposts or little red flags
that go up that you you will ignore and
I'll tell you how this works just
briefly the bottom of the bridge when I
say the bottom of the bridge what I mean
by that is this the whole Scientology
experience is called the bridge to total
freedom right those initial courses that
you do are actually valuable they mean
there is a communication course that
teaches you the exact communication
formula and if you apply this in your
life there's no two ways about it you're
gonna do better you'll be able to handle
situations and handle people and get on
better than before you did the course
and there's other things that you do
these are confidence builders and once
you do that somewhere along the line
something may be introduced to you that
you think I don't know if I agree with
this this is but everything so far
they've told me has been true I'll
accept it right that's it at that point
you looked Ron let me ask that point let
me ask you this though were there actual
because I've spoken to a lot of former
Scientologists and while they describe
the same mechanism you're describing for
how they get sort of pulled in further
and further none of them have reported
sort of genuinely believing like the
creation story of Scientology which
includes this absurd age of the earth
for example or stories about Xenu did
you believe that stuff as well let me
tell you and I'll say this first of all
I accepted it now I guess you could say
I have a bit more of an analytical mind
than the average person walking the
streets in other words what I mean by
that is this
I heard the story about the problem
being in his sector of the universe
overpopulation 150 billion people per
planet what I thought was this how the
hell are you gonna get all these people
down here in dc-8
these are not big airplane very
practical analysis very practical but
you know what I said well everything
they told me so far yeah I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna have to accept this do
you see that I'm going to have to accept
it to be a good Scientologist right and
I'm telling you man it's it's very
nefarious it's very very tricky the way
this happens and there's a lot of other
things like little rules that you have
to follow don't talk about your case in
other words what I mean by that is this
your reaction to life other than looking
at life exactly the way it is would be
called your case the way you react to it
you get counseling or auditing don't
talk to anybody about what happens in
your auditing session so you can't
compare notes with somebody else and say
hey wait a minute I think this is a
bunch of crap what do you think no if
you do that you're in trouble you have
to go to see the ethics officer and you
have to pay for confessional oddity at
your expense let's pause there let's
pause there because I think it's a good
good spot to take a quick break we're
speaking with Ron Miscavige who escaped
from the Church of Scientology's
international headquarters he's the
father of the current leader of the
Church of Scientology David Miscavige
and that's where we'll pick up our
conversation we're continuing our
conversation with Ron Miscavige who
escaped from the Church of Scientology's
international headquarters in 2012 he's
the father of the leader of the church
David Miscavige I want to talk a little
bit about how your son ultimately
ascended to be the leader of the church
but before we do that Ron you talked
about you use the word escaped you
escaped for the church talk to us about
for the people who've not heard this
what mechanisms are there that are
keeping you there such that you would
even use the word escape
your own mind that's what's keeping you
there you and as I said earlier in the
programs people care to read my book
you're gonna see the modus operandi how
exactly this is done little incremental
agreements little gradient bit-by-bit
you build up agreements in your own mind
so that you literally build a mental
prison that keeps you there
matter of fact but there there are
people who have left the church and
they'll agree with me when I say this if
you were to take a bus and crash that
gate in Hemet California and go on the
base where there are people there many
of whom have been there 10 20 30 and
even 40 years I don't know if you'd get
one person they did on that bus to get
out you could tell them listen we'll
give you a job we'll give you $20,000
we'll give you a place to live I don't
know any takers but there are some
people who are being held there more
than just mentally or psychologically I
mean I've spoken at some of them right
exactly right
yeah so now what was the point we were
bringing up here sort of what what the
nature of using the world scape was yeah
ok so look if I would have said to them
I'm tired of this
I don't want to be here anymore I want
to leave I would still be there my wife
and I would have been seized we would
have put under guard we would have been
guarded 24 hours a day we would have
been sit down in front of an E major and
have to cough up our transgressions
against the group daily on for hours and
hours and hours and when we weren't
doing that we'd be doing labor physical
labor now I knew that I couldn't get out
by just saying I want to leave so my
wife and I Becky planned our escape it
took us six months to plan that escape
and I can tell you this
we had a plan it down to the detail as
an example one of the things I would do
to make it okay for me to go from one
part of the base to the other part of
the base every Sunday morning was this
on Sunday morning
they have what they call CSP queenship
project where you clean your apartment
and you have some breakfast around nine
o'clock in the morning but between 9:00
and 12:00 you're cleaning every Sunday
morning I would drive from the south
side of the base through one of the
gates that was not worried guards work
go to the north side because on the
north side was the music studio where I
worked there was a refrigerator there we
couldn't have any food in our apartments
in that refrigerator I kept Italian
salami maybe Parmesan cheese some treats
and then I would drive through the main
gate where the guards were and every
Sunday morning I would give them some
cheese some salami in other words I was
getting them acclimated to the fact that
they'd see me going across the north
side and coming back where they were and
they'd get a treat it's feeding the
watchdog's in other words okay yep so
now six months of planning of sending
things off the base the people that we
knew so we could have at least some
things when we left come Sunday morning
9 o'clock in the morning I Drive out
from our apartment and by the way this
whole story is in a book just for your
listeners I Drive past the the mess hall
and there were only two guards on duty
on Sunday morning one of the guards was
at the main booth that was Jurgen and
the other guard would be down in the
mess hall having breakfast he had what
they call the chase car that was south
now I passed that place and I saw the
car there and I knew that by the time I
got to the gate down the road which was
about 200 yards down from the main gate
Sal would still be having breakfast now
my car is loaded with my horns my
exercise equipment clothes if the guard
would have said come up to the main
booth I was dead in the water I pressed
the button didn't say award the gate
opened up I said to my wife we're
turning left I trumped on that gas pedal
and we were going about 80 miles an hour
down the road and about a mile down the
road there was a decision to be made
where you either turn right which was
route 10 it would take you to LA go
straight on route 60 which would take
you to LA or turn left and go into town
I knew that once Jurgen saw that I was
leaving he'd be on his Nextel yelling
run what the hell are you doing get back
here and then he'd be on the phone would
sell by the time sell in the chase car
got after the booth I would be at that
decision point and I decided to turn
left for sure he would think I was going
right on route 10 or correct excuse me
straight ahead on route 60 once we
turned left and got into town I was free
well at that point I knew I had escaped
successfully we drove across the United
States for about two and a half days I
paid for everything with cash because if
I would have used my credit card that
would have traced me send somebody out
on an airplane and captured me and
taking me back incredible that old that
old story is in the book I just
mentioned Ron how did David who now is
the leader of the church how did he end
up in that position I'll tell you how we
ended up in that position and this is an
interesting story and I I go into it in
detail in the book which of course
doesn't have to keep on saying that but
I do look have you ever heard the
expression power tends to corrupt and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
of course okay now I always thought it
was Winston Churchill who said that that
was a gentleman by the name of Lord
Acton he lived from 1834 till early
1900's he was a member of parliament he
is the one who said that and by the way
he also said which very few people know
great men are almost always bad men
and the hell of a statement now here's
what happened to David when he was
sixteen fifteen years old he was going
to be 16 I came home from work one day
walked in a house and he's in his
bedroom kind of leaning back with his
head in his hands and I saw he was
pondering something I said Dave what's
up man he's that he's I don't want to go
to school
more ice what do you mean you don't want
to go to school anymore he's and look at
he's AI just none of the kids listen to
the teacher they take drugs
I want to go help l ron Hubbard well to
me this was a shot but I thought to
myself you know what when I was 17 years
old I decided I wanted to join the
Marine Corps mm-hmm now my dad had to
sign for me because unless you're 18 you
can't go on your own volition and I
remember him saying to me Ronnie are you
sure you know what the hell you're doing
these guys are the first ones in and I
said yes dad I want to join the Marines
as it turned out that turned out to be
one of the best decisions I've ever made
in my life from the first night in boot
camp where I said this is the worst
goddamn mistake I've ever made in my
life - twelve weeks later when I thought
to myself I can make myself do anything
they've turned me in from an
undisciplined civilian into a
disciplined United States Marine that
has served me well my whole life I
thought of that and I thought of David
and I thought you know what he's already
a trained auditor if he wants to help l
ron Hubbard it's probably the best thing
you could do and I agreed to help him
and I helped him join got him a ticket
I got him closed gave him some money he
joined us the organization and within
seven months he was working with l ron
Hubbard over the years he worked himself
up into a position where he was at the
point of all communication going to l
ron Hubbard went through him and all
communication going from l ron Hubbard
came through him out to the public or
out to staff and that's he actually had
an experience though which I will
quickly get it because I guess we're
running out of time a little bit hmm
and that was this you remember I said he
never had another attack once he had
that auditing session from Frank ogle
right right he did have a severe attack
however as a staff member so severe that
he had to go to the emergency room at
the hospital guy to the name of Paul
Grady took him there and Paul told me
this story
David got out of the emergency room he
said to Paul Paul I just had one hell of
a realization
Paul said what's that he said that is
this power is not granted it is assumed
and he assumed the leadership of
Scientology and when l ron Hubbard died
he pushed people out of the way who
would object to him being there put his
own people in and rose right to the top
and he's headed to church ever since and
that's how he took over when you see
reports Ron about how your son Gabriel
averaged in his role as leader of the
Church of Scientology is regularly
handing out physical beatings to people
and is sort of a megalomaniac does that
strike you as credible or not credible
based on your knowledge of your son well
let's put it this way I never knew him
as that type of person I got to say that
because you know people are expecting me
to say oh yeah he was the son of a [ __ ]
from the word go no that's not true when
he was a little kid I am Telling You we
got along famously
he had a great sense of humor he was a
tough little kid he just a real spark a
little he played peewee league football
I used to have to put a two and a half
pound plate in each of his shorts
pockets to make the minimum weight for
him to play and he could tackle anybody
his size I firmly believe that it was
the power that got to him that turned
him from dr. Jekyll into mr. Hyde I'm
absolutely positive of that I never saw
it before in my life but this was
firsthand and as an example he got my
daughter's a disconnect from me
yeah I no longer no longer have a family
I couldn't do that to another person I
mean they want to leave the church it
the way it was I mean I lived in a base
where every every letter you wrote had
to be checked by security guards if it
wasn't okay you had to rewrite it you
couldn't make a phone call out you had
to have somebody listening in on an
extension you couldn't leave the base to
go shopping you had to buy all your
stuff on the internet I mean it just
we're living in a compound like like
prisoners
I know I wanted to leave and I can't see
why they should say okay fine you're out
of here not the case I no longer have a
family
he's got my family and here's here's the
way this connection works by the way
let's say my daughter Denise were to
talk to me she has a daughter in the C
organization Tara would no longer speak
to Denise again right if Laurie were to
speak to me she works for a Scientology
employer she'd go to work that day
you're fired
so it's it's the whole thing is neatly
set up for controller there's beyond
beyond belief well it is an incredibly
disturbing story and I I do really
appreciate you sharing it with our
audience we've been speaking with Ron
Miscavige who is the father of the
Church of Scientology's leader David
Miscavige the real Ron Miscavige calm is
the one and only website that actually
has anything to do with Ron Ron thanks
so much for talking to me David thank
you very much for having me on I really
appreciate